I don't come
[Music]
Can you attach one pork bowl and two red ginger? I'll be in
Ruta Doha.
Is it okay? I'm tired.
It's
like
this.
[Music] I'm
buying a car. It's
a terrible guy. [Music] What a terrible guy.
Brader Sada Maki Kenji was a confident project for
his relatives who misunderstood the work of the black one,
but the
result was not
obtained.
I don't know if it was really good or not
because I'm an amateur, but it's still
difficult, is
n't it? But I can't compromise because I started from myself
today
[Music]
I'm addicted to thinking about reassuring
somewhere Table tennis  I'm sorry to have kept you waiting
. Thank you for your
good story.
I'll try again.
That's the best thing.
Please do your best.
Germany, the additional reproduction monster, will
rider super g 3 at a later date
[Applause]